oh the gumbo my name is Ranbir and
welcome to glamour bus I'm working
everybody I thought I was surprised how
many enjoy that last video but you bros
obviously wanted more and now give me
more aiya done ah how's it going man I
don't know how to go in there that's
what he said nothing I told her what I
wanted to say I just but why would they
not go there
because it smells and it's sticky I
guess that makes sense
I you can never know what its mouth
sticky what did you say because its
mouth and sticky
we asked my yeah that's what I meant to
say obviously that's why he asked me
twice oh I thought you a great number of
things mentioned one this guy I get the
feeling he wants to piss whoa there's a
lot more people talking now since I did
how did you know I didn't know yeah all
right you got it right for first time
congratulations you are somehow smart
are you smarter than you at least some
other than I should have asked how smart
he is
what planet are you from
come on this is [ __ ] he's the one
leading the conversation I wanted to
step up the game and asked him to marry
me do you have a yes I have a body
I'm from Eric I'm not a bot like you
come on man you're pissing me pay what I
don't like to discuss scary things me
neither it's creepy
have you heard about Slenderman meanie
that takes a doctor about is it really
we are friends
what doctor Slenderman what your flat
friends with dr. Slenderman what the
hell what is Frederick Douglas it might
want ago I did want to ask that though
what Frederick Douglas and Matt want to
have see nothing you say makes any sense
anymore I'm afraid I'm going to have to
just leave you what don't leave me I was
about to ask you if you wanted to marry
me see that something as bad as you do
want to marry I guess it's true Thank
You Nicholas fair enough what's your
favorite movie
I enjoy Clockwork Orange what about here
you
and what about your ear yeah that makes
sense
yes nothing else what about your ear yes
are you single yes all right finally
moving forward with this quest come on
man no are you single
no are you single that was his problem
what oh man I can't wait to see what the
[ __ ] he makes out of this know you are a
single pop yeah that's true yes why
would should you care you don't even
know me why don't you tell me something
about yourself
why did you tell me something about
yourself
am I really pronounced using that bad
I didn't where do you live yes finally I
have to articulate a billion yeah I live
in Poland that's nice
how is Poland how to Poland yeah of
course it makes so much [ __ ] sense
where do you want to go somewhere
private and talk
no I'm busy busy with what what the hell
this is really what the house life what
the hell is that supposed to mean he's
getting on my nerves right now it's
[ __ ] rude and [ __ ] I do not know how
I I do not know I do not know how I feel
would you like to go and pee finish with
an and come on game done come on I can
do this yes would you like to go out and
oh make sweet love to your ass what make
sweet love to you what and say that I
don't want to do that gay maybe time and
location I'm not gonna go what time is
it
ah it's time for sweet lovin man
how many baths does it take to change
the light bulb don't change the subject
brow dump the subject of course no he is
a character on Glee
I don't watch Glee seriously that I
don't want man you just said you want to
meet yes tell me where you want to meet
and I would be there
I will bring wine I will bring cheese
I will bring condoms what no I want now
I will just be there it will be a fun
little thing you don't have to tell
anyone about it if you don't what the
hell why did you just end like that I
wasn't done
you tell me where you want to meet and
it would be there I will bring wine
every room please I will bring condoms
what I want and I will definitely do
that if a boyfriend a little thing you
do not tell anyone about it what day you
get out of school I don't go to school
stop asking me best things tell me Adam
does school start let me test it oh boy
or girl's name are you a boy or a girl
and do you have tits are you a boy or a
girl in rehab tech come on man
girl MIT hello I mean how'd it go I
don't take them that show me your tits
come on man why to see my tattoo no I
want to see your titties send pictures
no I went to see your titty okay where
like I changed genders yesterday was a
boy what the [ __ ] you are just show me
your tits man I mean girl just tell me
again Amiga your name is Jefferson do
you have a penis or a vagina
yeah the penis stop stop I don't get I
don't get it either man
but I have to end it here okay can that
Gaga ah it's so frustrating talking to
you man hahaha you Oh Lucy you are funny
I'm not that funny
come on alright I have to end it here do
you want to say something to finish it
off maybe something in Swedish do you
speak Swedish
last time you spoke Danish and you said
it was Swedish what is it there if you
want to say something to finish it off
maybe something is this the greatest nap
this is the greatest nap ever I'm
picking the subjects here Bob all right
I have to enter their brofist man okay
brofist bro [ __ ] best
I'm tented brothers mad ok bro bro
[ __ ] best bro bro good to know
I am proud to say that the underworld
officially has great internet connection
- are you saying I'm going to hell bro
what the hell bro what bro what
Brook I say about abracadabra watch
Brooklyn okay we're not getting anywhere
okay I have to do what I said I would do
Rick Lee okay 100 do you want to marry
me I don't need a black I really enjoyed
is this guy recovery today and next time
we will go on our honeymoon no no no no
no no no no no no no no I'm backing up
that's not looking down looking out me
contain it